president Trump unloading on Obama
administration officials after newly
declassified documents identified them
in the unmasking of Michael Flint the
big name on the list
sleepy Joe Biden his campaign is denying
any wrongdoing but Trump says they all
got caught it was the greatest political
crime in the history of our country if I
were a Democrat instead of a Republican
I think everybody would have been in
jail a long time ago and I'm talking
with 50 year sentences it is a disgrace
what's happened this is the greatest
political scam hoax in the history of
our country
so Trump also saying he wants Barack
Obama himself to testify all right well
I don't think that's gonna happen cuz
that's not how we do things in this
country but Juan don't you think people
like clapper and and powers and rice
should come in and answer the question
if you guys knew there was no evidence
of collusion because you said it under
oath why were you out there on national
TV telling the American people for years
there was collusion well I don't think
anybody's reluctant to testify in this
situation because it would be good just
to clear it up let me just give you a
point of reference here Jesse you know
there are thousands of unmasking that
take place every year under all
administration's and that includes the
Trump administration what it says is in
2019 last year the Trump administration
had ten thousand plus on maskings the
year before 16,000 plus unmasking and
the senior administration officials and
Telus officials need that for context to
understand the degree to which our
country is being threatened by hostile
actors you know the case here would be
Russian interference in the 2016
cancelin then one let me ask you a
hypothetical question here okay so if
you're George Bush's team after eight
years started unmasking all of these
incoming Obama national security
officials and then sent them in to FBI
agents to interview them and then and
then lock them up do you think that
would be okay for a perfectly legal
conversation again I think you're
ignoring the context that we had a
threat to our democratic let's see
exactly what I hostile state the
Russians that's what we were doing with
Jesse and so they had to take a look
just one last point to one when they
when they wrote a long we got it alone
okay okay let's move it along
Dana
how do you see these things now moving
forward after we know about the
unmasking well one thing I would say to
want is that not all on maskings are not
created equal so yes so you could have
10,000 plus and maskings in a year but
you don't necessarily have the unmasking
happening in the middle of a
presidential transition from one
administration to the next after the
political opponent had just won so
there's there's that I don't know why I
have beeping in my ear but I do and so
maybe I should pass it along to somebody
else I don't think that anyone is going
to testify it's like somebody's trying
to call me but I don't have a phone on
one says you know you're not allowed to
talk to a hostile power or else you're
gonna get unmasked and then prosecuted
for crimes but we don't know what the
crimes are I thought Democrats liked
talking to our enemies I mean they talk
to the Iranians I don't see why we
shouldn't be able to talk to the
Russians the Chinese anybody but this
judge now this judge Sullivan who's
dealing with Flint has appointed another
judge to recommend to him why he should
lock up Mike Flynn even though
prosecutors say he's innocent what kind
of sense does that make
right and I will be really fast here
this is just the general overview he can
absolutely do that he can stretch this
process out he can bring in some type of
neutral voice to look at everything he
can even hold hearings on factual
discrepancies within the record going
back in that development but the bottom
line is that case law holds he has to
uphold this motion to dismiss it is
literally it is absolutely ridiculous
for him to think that he can do anything
other than come to that conclusion
everything else in the interim is
wasting taxpayer dollars and the fact
that this is likening this to some type
of cronyism no that's what we should see
in Chicago that has nothing to do with
what the DOJ concluded here in their
emotion which was that they identified
that corruption and that this motion to
dismiss is the result of that
investigation this is wasting our time
and money yeah Greg it looks like
Sullivan's weighed a lot maybe you've
been trying to force the President to
pardon Flynn what do you think it
imagine
you won the World Series and the
baseball commissioner announced hey you
know what we're gonna add a post World
Series tournament to really find out who
the winner is nobody wants this to go
forward this is a terrible thing that he
did even if it is legal but you know
what for everything else payback is a
pregnant dog think about how lush this
is everything the Democrats accused
Trump of doing turns out they're guilty
of it they here literally literally of
sounding like Emily engineering a scheme
to spy on a candidate so it's really
important that all those idiots that
spent that voice in three years of hell
on us get their licks they've got it
they've got to be punished it's like a
movie where the villain has a gun on
your hero and then the villain looks
away and the hero grabs a gun and points
it at the villain that's what just
happened the guys with the guns now have
the guns on them so let's make it work
they deserve punishment they made our
lives hell let's make their lives help
why not turn it down again is fair play
still don't know what game show that is
alright make it up making people's lives
hell that's what we do you